police are holding a news conference
after a shooting that left two people
dead and a third critically injured
let's just listen in two of whom have
sadly died
the third victim remains in hospital
with critical injuries
inquiries are ongoing to notify all next
of kin
our thoughts are very much with their
families today
well I cannot discuss the details of the
homicide officer's investigation
I can confirm that at this stage there
have been no arrests
there are a number of crime scenes in
place and we thank local residents for
their understanding and cooperation
[Applause]
well our forensic and specialist crime
colleagues do their job
we understand that the community will
quite rightly be shocked by this
horrific incident and we share in their
concerns however I can assure you that
my dedicated colleagues from The
Specialist crime command are working at
a place to collect evidence and identify
the Suspects
I ask that you can support them by
sharing any information that you have
there will also be additional offices
patrolling the area over the coming days
if you have any information or concerns
then please do speak to them they are
there to protect and support you
if you do not want to speak directly to
the police please do get in touch with
the independent charity Crime Stoppers
anonymously
shocking acts of violence like this
motivates every single officer in the
Met to catch those responsible
bring Justice to their families and take
weapons off the streets
tackling violence remains front and
center of our focus and we are working
with partners and The Wider Community to
tackle the root cause of these
devastating crimes and find long-term
Solutions
however we cannot do it alone which is
why is so important that you speak up
either about this incident or any other
act of violence that you're aware of so
that together we can make your area a
safer place
thank you very much for your time